biden's first official state of the
union is now in the books and as
expected it was an unmitigated
predictable disaster platitudes bumper
stickers slogans you name it you know
filled with smoke and mirrors detached
from reality seemingly written to be
honest by a
kid in kindergarten maybe first grade if
we're being generous
delivered by someone in a steep mental
decline he failed to acknowledge his
afghan failure he failed to acknowledge
his border failures he failed to mention
his failures on clovid by the way how
did we run out of tests around christmas
how come we ran out of monoclonal
antibodies over christmas he failed to
acknowledge that he caused this
inflation because of his economic and
energy policies he failed to say the
main sanction that would have worked on
putin which is
yes energy no imports no exports a
russian energy but he refuses to do do
so instead
uh as i said bumper stickers slogans
platitudes cliches and to be honest i
would have preferred to watch the
president of ukraine who is now bravely
fighting
and leading a war against this russian
invasion and tonight if the world was
looking for any american leadership they
didn't get it from joe biden this speech
defined america last night america first
and by the way
joe lied over and over and over again we
can start with jobs take a look
that's one of the first things i did as
president was fight to pass the american
rescue plan
because people were hurting
we needed to act and we did
it worked we created jobs lots of jobs
in fact our economy created over
6.5 million new jobs just last year
more jobs
in one year
than ever before in the history of the
united states of america
that is a flat out lie under biden the
u.s is down 3 million jobs we're not up
and here's another lie from biden take a
look
under my plan nobody let me say this
again nobody earning less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year will pay
an additional penny in new taxes not a
single penny
he's been telling that lie since he
became president but according to the
analysts biden's spending and tax plans
will definitely impact those making
under four hundred thousand dollars a
year and we're not even factoring biden
inflation which is well impacting the
poor in the middle class the most in
this country that's right you pay more
to fill up your car paying more to heat
and cool your home and you're paying
more for every product you buy at every
store you go to and get this we're now
at a 40-year high for inflation joe
didn't mention that tonight and
according to studies from the wharton
school of business and the congressional
budget office inflation is costing the
typical american family upwards of five
thousand dollars a year and that number
continues to rise that would be a tax on
the poor in the middle class but tonight
joe's genius solution to inflation
just spend more money and encourage
businesses to lower their costs oh okay
joe thanks for the help
too many families are struggling to keep
up with their bills
inflation
is robbing them of gains they thought
otherwise they would be able to feel
i get it
that's why my top priority is getting
prices under control look
our economy roared back faster than
almost anyone predicted but pandemic
meant that businesses
had a hard time hiring enough people
because of the pandemic to keep up
production in their factories
she didn't have people making those
beams that went in the buildings because
they were out the factory was closed
i think i have a better idea to fight
inflation
lower your cost not your wages
pure fantasy from the mind of a career
politician who clearly does not
understand simple basic economics 101 or
business and to that end joe biden just
basically all night bret baer nailed it
he repackaged buildback broke better
socialism tonight and he hoped that
nobody would notice take a look
let's cut energy costs for families
an average of 500 a year by combating
climate change let's provide an
investment tax credits to weatherize
your home and your business
to be energy efficient and get a tax
credit for it
double americans clean energy production
in solar wind and so much more lower the
price of electric vehicles saving
another eighty dollars a month that
you're not going to have to pay at the
pump
what joe didn't tell you he has put more
restrictions on exploration and energy
extraction than any president in the
modern era you see it because gas prices
are shooting through the roof they have
nearly doubled in the last year but
guess what new tax credits for electric
cars great biden just bragged about
releasing oil from the strategic reserve
and as joe manchin said it is a gimmick
at best will do nothing to curb the
prices in any significant way so make no
mistake biden's socialist green new deal
energy
plans they're fraudulent at best biden
is not making america greener or safer
instead he's restricting domestic
production of oil and gas that lowers
the world's supply of energy and as the
demand remains constant or increases
that just increases the price and you
know what every american knows it and
meanwhile he's outsourcing our energy
industry to countries that by the way
have no epa countries that hate america
he's begging opec even russia and trying
to make a deal with iran uh and
importing let's see 232 million barrels
of oil from russia last year a million
barrels of oil from iran last year over
600 million barrels of oil from opec
last year when we have more natural
resources than all of those countries
combined and under biden america's crude
oil imports from russia actually doubled
and tonight despite putin's ongoing
invasion in spite of his war crimes the
u.s continues to import 500 000 barrels
of oil every single day
from russia now we could produce this
oil and gas right here at home and by
the way he inherited america energy
independent and a net exporter of energy
we could be helping our nato and western
european allies but biden put a new
pause on oil and geese gas leases on
america the same day that russia invaded
ukraine the same exact day that's why
biden's comments on ukraine tonight were
totally impotent and meaningless and
frankly i would have heard from
president zielinski who has shown
nothing nothing but courage and bravery
in ukraine take a look
we spent months building coalitions of
other freedom-loving nations in europe
and the americas to america to the asian
and african continents
to confront putin
like many of you i spent countless hours
unifying your european allies
together along with our allies we are
right now enforcing powerful economic
sanctions
we're cutting off russia's largest banks
in the international financial system
preventing russia's central bank from
defending the russian ruble ruble
putin may circle kiev with tanks
but he'll never gain the hearts and
souls of the iranian people
joe they're ukrainians they're not
iranians america the world needs a
leader not a grandpa who is up way past
his bedtime and get this only moments
ago biden actually was scolding the
american people for using covert 19 as a
political wedge take a look
you know we've lost so much in cover 19.
time with one another
the worst of all the much loss of life
let's use this moment to reset
so stop looking at coven as a partisan
dividing line
see it for what it is a god-awful
disease
let's stop sending each seen each other
as enemies
and start seeing each other for who we
are
fellow americans
hey remember 2020 biden ran on a promise
he'd shut down the virus and in 2021 we
had more people dead from covert than
2020. remember joe demanded president
trump resigned after 400 000 americans
died from covert 19 since he's been
president over 540 000 americans have
died from covid under his watch uh
that's a lot more than donald trump and
by the way after biden ran out of tests
monoclonal antibodies antivirals when we
needed them the most around christmas
time and all of a sudden joe no longer
wants to play you know politics with
covert 19. okay joe a contributing
factor to biden's covert crisis is
america's wide open borders on that
issue he failed miserably also and he
failed to mention that tonight border
patrol made a record 1.9 million arrests
at the border under biden of course we
had process and release no more stay in
mexico no more building the wall we have
no idea how many millions were not
apprehended but we do know that around a
half a million illegal immigrants were
released into the u.s and they were
given free transportation all over the
country and preferential treatment they
didn't need cover tests because gensake
told us they weren't going to be here
very long really then we had the
overcrowded cages of joe biden in the
middle of a pandemic there was no
vaccine mandate for illegal immigrants
no tests whatsoever but now a midterm
you know conversion or election year
conversion as we call them and all of a
sudden biden wants to secure the border
he also suddenly wants to fund not
defund the police after two years a d
fund dismantled no bail laws joe's
decided to turn turn around do a
complete 180. take a look
we should all agree the answer is not to
defund the police
it's to fund the police
fund
fun
why didn't you say that when it would
have mattered in the summer of 2020 when
dozens of americans died thousands of
american police were hurt you know with
bricks rocks bottles molotov cocktails
billions of dollars in property damage
are arson and looting
you know a truly amazing election year
conversion if ever there was one and
it's uh no surprise after democrats
attempted to defund dismantle you know
no bail laws that police departments are
reporting violent crime is spiking
especially in every major american city
12 major cities just set an all-time
high for murder great job joe and
tonight you might have noticed something
interesting biden did not mention any
accomplishments none whatsoever
because there are none a barrel of oil
tonight is at 107 dollars per barrel
inflation is at a 40-year high crime is
spiking we still have open borders we
still have record-setting covert deaths
no real mention at all of afghanistan
where he abandoned americans people with
american green cards are afghan allies
and guess what it's day 199 americans
held behind enemy lines and joe just
turned the page the media mob has turned
the page as well
and as for that unity that joe promised
last year according to a recent poll
more americans say biden is dividing the
country and he's rather than unifying
the country and according to a
georgetown survey voters say politics is
less civil one year into this biden term
so instead of listing accomplishments
that usually kind of happens during a
state of the union biden just read off a
wish list of far left socialist
proposals that they made before
everything from entitlements to solar
panels and even david axelrod top
democrat under obama he had to tweet out
quote it's hard to avoid making a state
of the union sound like a laundry list
the tide did not turn tonight but once i
agree with david axelrod hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else